joining me here now on the Rich Eisen
show he is in the original movie on
crackle party boat and I love this man I
don't care who knows it
good to see you JJ JJ hey I guess my dog
pirate you know cuz she got the thing
with the I see you have we may see again
Kwan Bolden yes the GAO was Alexandra
Daddario Mohawks we've got like a
pornhub premium and account over here
that's true retires like bro you're like
three catches from being eighth what are
you doing I know he said he wants to
make the world a better place JJ you
know you make a world a better place
make people in western New York happy
like once in a while start by Lake Erie
that's a start menu 30 catches from like
six I know I've done the analytics which
you now as you know we must describe
things for the radio audience as well
Jake okay
why well what is that who do you home
and watch your favorite radio show who
do you have on your lap right here when
a pillow is on my lap she's a she's a
beauty she's right here sitting on my
what type of dog is yeah well you just
ruined it for the radio folks how about
your small crazy one of their vomits out
of the oven they're really hot like half
Chris Meyers and half was a half Meyers
I'm I'm hurt I'm here you're there look
like Bob's Big Boy looks like Chris
Hanson sounds like Chris Hanson rich
I've heard you've got this radio TV
thing going on how's that how's that
going on what is it on how do I find it
rich a lot of dancing on to catch a
predator mabel's my dog a Yorkie little
three pound dog but it's like I can't
leave her in the car it's hot I
should've thought this forward no oh
bring the dog with me to work Mike
Michael Chiklis was on the show but
about three months ago which was the
3000th he brought his pug named after
Tom Brady he named his pug Tom Brady got
he damn well did I got a Tony Eason
Maltese at home
maltese by the way that was brawny
mEagle a rescue
well yeah always so Mabel's my teacup
Yorkie in my lap Antoine bold and we
cover Chris Hanson yes catch a predator
the one word he can't say the most
important word of the show we like
freaks out as a speech impediment
it turns in like X rated match game it
goes well when I read the emails I want
to take you and blank and blank and then
it seems like you came here for sex he's
like the only speech if enemy has is the
one most important word yeah you think
I mean you drove all the way from Berea
Ohio to Jacksonville Florida for shad
sex
can I go you're free to go by the way
great gene Rayburn reference as well a
love match game however if there's a
match game marathon I'll die in bed a
thousand percent I will die in bed
well done well done I like they were so
drunk they simplified it to the point of
a or b and the contestants were like
they thought it was strategy they're
hammered they're like huh B if you could
ever be on a game show which one would
not shoot don't be so hasty J you know
me you know sometimes I jump the gun
which are we holster do it again
hope nobody died ah [ __ ] sharks card
sharks higher lower higher lower I'm
freezing right there but if I was I
named that tune they'd have to fix the
game to get me off really how about you
really you could name that tune in a
couple notes really let's start for
those three notes you got it's not
playing out hold on Mike can you choose
something from an era where we're
allowed to to play it right yeah Mike's
a big in the catalogue by the way party
boat on crackle it's it's on your phone
right now
oh yeah a cracker lapid story today
August 22 where they named it party boat
they don't want you to go what's that
movie about well I think it could be
about anything in the world of sports
the Learning Channel the man with 135
pound scrotum what this is about people
making chocolate sometimes you just got
to be obvious you know what I mean it's
a party boat it was the most fun I've
ever had on a set in my life and I've
been I'm on now come on
I've no reason to make I'm talking to
you which I know that Jay Wright it was
insane fun you're on a boat for four
days you're just on a boat adrift like
yeah they're just playing hip-hop the
whole time dancing and people are
running around in bikinis did you bring
your Yorkie with you then the girls show
up which is you and a bunch of dudes in
bikini stretch you know they call it a
glory hole for a reason glory when you
hit that endzone body what are we
talking about
I took mushrooms like a half hour ago I
wanna be honest with you so I can't even
look
why is Eric Dickerson your sound guy
it's not him it's not there it's not
there it's not realize that is the truth
that is the truth table so we didn't
play name that tune you want to do that
okay now a mic on but you have to tell
him don't you have to give a hint as to
what the song is you want to hear it
dashana what is the genre all right
I am gold 80 70s antboy let's start
again
I am gold 7:00 a.m. gold seventies
because there's our early eighties okay
I am gold and had two big hits hold on
man yo this is why you're not a game
show host or an audio exactly okay go
ahead okay I interrupt incessantly but
let me like slow my roll everybody needs
to just slow their roll if you made that
upset now you happy okay I'm sorry you
wonder why I eat let's start again
go and tell - for what Jay Mohr who had
the floor he wants to play name that
tune you are you are the Tom Kennedy
remember that remember he was the host
okay you're the Tom Kennedy go for it so
this is an am song big 70s song group
had two good songs this was number one
and their big hit although they're it's
the first part of that sentence is like
Morse code of English thanks from pretty
much that's my Livingston Joisey nobody
from Jersey ever said Joisey Jersey bro
we got hammered me a short yellow phupho
what what exit bro what highway 145
oranges north left yes you know what I
mean where's the gravy where did the
gravy come from what you saying Jersey
that sauce rich you know I told you
yesterday about the strawberries a 70s
hit played on AM radio band this band
had two hits this is the number one hit
okay
is that enough of information for you do
you would you need to know how many know
how many notes can you name this in one
one note ok Delta folk go for it
oh do we give it to one more time oh you
did nice you're deaf oh no I can't do it
anymore give me four
okay did you play already though here it
comes hang on till to foe
come on Mike party boat dude party blah
hashtag party boat hashtag party boat
more on crackle on August 24th that's
today can you not do it now all of us
hold play play why is Jason worth
holding his legs under clike repeating
over no no no no no that that's Bryce
Harper getting hurt that you're saying
[Music]
Boogie Nights buddy got which one is it
couldn't get it right climax blues band
no he's just
[Music]
it really is the worst song song Leeson
on $64,000 pyramid you ever had one I'm
a nominally a jerk Oh what are you
having the Mayweather McGregor fight
that's our poll question to make sure
legitimize I would risk one guy is a
boxer in a boxing match and the other
guy who does leg kicks and chokes so
every time he's practicing a Darth choke
mmm-hmm any time he's practicing a rear
naked choke Kimura anytime he's armbar
any time we shot the legs anytime
somebody went sprawl sprawl mm-hmm Floyd
Mayweather from the age of six on I
don't you guys know this he's pretty
good boxer never Holly Holm just punched
the snot out of the greatest fighter we
had ever seen you know Ronda Rousey
decided to stand in front of Holly
Holmes it's Holly Holm is better than
Berto better than you know Gennaro
Hernandez it's Holly Holm is better than
guys like Shane Mosley so you're taking
Floyd Mayweather in this fight is what
he was taking him physically as my lover
[Laughter]
taking Conor McGregor in a boxing match
everybody I got Tom Brady beating up
Bryce Harper in the softball match
mm-hmm that's like that is even closer
than one we're talking yeah but that
means Brady could maybe catch a few
balls and be able to hit one over the
fence just stop it
all I said was I bet you're probably
right what I'm saying is - one guy
entire life
yeah has been one Bruce Lee don't show
me 10,000 punches show me the man
there's still one punch ten thousand
times no Russell Brand
don't show me ten thousand punches
Taylor Swift oh is that your real name I
think it's Jeffrey told me the manager
one punch 10,000 times that would be mr.
Mayweather Cornyn McGregor looks nice I
bet he gets tearing up in a phone booth
swimming underwater but I don't think
he's gonna have a chance for the lighted
gloves a fight for a purse wearing silk
shorts the whole thing's a little erotic
didn't think Russell Brand would be
getting its two cents on me today
I don't know it looks I have a side
toupee
do you have a birthday yesterday JJ I
had a birthday yesterday Richard what'd
you do with your birthday yesterday Jay
Mohr I got up my son my six-year-old son
Mackie made me like a parfait a parfait
it's just like a big pile of stuff
parfait and I what do you make what you
suck face he had the right ingredients
okay it was a big bowl a big bowl of
parfait no ma'am you like puffy you like
puffy right and I took him to school
then I did a movie for a day this Brad
Pitt movie Oh like a tiny tiny tiny like
bit part won't do it just like okay
small all right there's no small parts
small actors I just hunched yeah why is
everybody so thirsty my god and then I
got I took a nap at work
god bless like a movie you get to lay in
a trailer everything happened for years
you got kids I know I don't know what it
is this this dude over there not good I
took a 90-minute nap yesterday what
amazing that's why nobody marches for
you you know what right up the Segundo
Boulevard right right straight through
Manhattan Beach into the ocean I don't
know where to go it's like Atlantis down
there hashtag rich rich must nap that's
what they say your dog has not moved you
know I don't know because he's a lap dog
she likes party boat did you go
on a party boat did you did you the
whole movie was filmed in this uh is it
Lake Fournier and I'm it was Fred smooth
there and you know a lot of Vikings good
good party boat reference right there
louder bike hashtag party book how dare
you so wiffle ball my way and expect
[Laughter]
wiffle ball and lightning both fights
you know it's making his way here right
now Michael Irvin you've known Keyshawn
like destroyed his own interview get out
of here you never lately cuz Mike was
calling and let me let me get this
straight right now
this that's my guy Mike I know that I
love from back in the foxglove
would you meet him on the set of Jerry
Maguire to briefly on that when you were
too far like he comes and goes and like
no Herman Moore just everyday hanging
out every day you dog just moved your
dog just be heard more these over to us
last name that's Mabel long Getty Queen
it's begun so a party boat you can avail
it's available right now for free on
crackle today watch it on his
PlayStation this morning is that right I
would take some it's like the most fun I
guess it's like the most I wouldn't sit
here and tell you like it's really great
you know we broke down the character
like break down the character a bunch of
goofy kids that we're like hilarious
kids yeah tell me what was your
motivation for playing officer Walsh in
party boat Jake I just wanted to be like
all the like the roles I set out for a
few years you know give a child so then
I just wanted to go like oh this is like
when I get to act legal oh I got to
actually act like a fool
hmm everybody goes like you just take it
down a little no they were like did you
like that
there you go would you do it your shirt
off I'm like oh if tell foo folk first
name Mattoon selection ever spinning
disks he prides himself on being a top
notch DJ I am can you try one more time
at least give him something given one
give him that spin and curve in a zone
for crying out what is the poll question
results as they currently stand as
Michael Irvin's make people think Conor
McGregor's
the question is the uestion is who
you're rooting for oh who are you
rooting for good point
so look at Jay Cutler's sourpuss in the
mouth Yeah right Conor McGregor 67%
people are rooting for him
yeah I'm a boxing fan so I'm rooting for
Floyd Mayweather I'm not a McGregor win
kind of would be said that like you're
in a commercial for an online college
I'm a boxing fan so I'm rooting for
Floyd knew I want to take a break we'll
come back we'll get that music teed up
Ervin's making his way here maybe we'll
throw him on the set with you for a
little dogs
he might be I don't know that makes a
big dude man would be afraid of that dog
come on come on JJ Mike is here JJ JJ is
here Michael Irvin's making his way here
you're there to do that I'm here I'm
Chris Myers you were there Michael
Irvin's making his way here we're back
with more in a moment the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show app
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show